そこで実際に生け花の何とか何とかという作品が実際に存在するんじゃなくて
その時一時的に現れた瞬間の現象なんです
あの皿だけ取ってみたら
もう大したことはないし
花別に一本一本取ってみたら
葉っぱとかね 何のこともないんです
例えばわざと生け花にこの汚いかっこ悪いものを植えるでしょ
別に取り出したら なんだこのゴミではないかと思うかもしれない
でも植えて生けてみたら
すっごい力が出しても話しかけてくれるんですね
ですから この生け花の世界を見ると
この現象というもののいかなるものかとわかるはずなんです
ですから 美しい花を生けら
生けているんだと すごいものだと
と言っても それは別に嘘じゃないんです
嘘じゃないんだけど それは実際実体ではないんだと
これこそ美しさだと 捕まるもの何もないんです
そこに ただ 色お互いに互いに助け合って
一部一部貢献して 美しさというものを演じているかいうか
もうなんとか一時的なものなんです
それは全てのものはそういうふうに
現象論で仏教は見ているんですね
瞬間しかない現象だと
音もそうであろうし 瞬間しかないし
他のものもそうであるし
食べ物はおいしいということは永遠な変化しない真理ではなくて
その瞬間の感覚なんですよ
人が年取るたびに この食べ物に対する感情が変わっていっちゃう
ですから それをずっと永遠な不変たる真理ではなくて
その時その時の感情によって
態度によって 美味しいか美味しくない
美味しくないかというふうになってしまっちゃうし
今まで栄養をとっていた食べ物がある
ある ある日から毒になるかもしれませんし
それはもう確実になるんです
自分たちの国だったらありますよ
たまに治療を受けたり
薬を飲んだりすると 毎日食べてる食べ物なんですが
あれとこれとこれとこれが絶対食べるなと
それでも患者さんが多分美味しいと思ってるんじゃ
死にたければ食べなさいと
そういうふうに言われる時もありますよ
ということは 毎日食べてる美味しい食べ物やというものでも
たまに毒になる可能性もありますし
ですから そういう全ての現象
一つも残らず一切の現象っていうのは現象であって
一時的であって その時の条件によってある一つの状態を演じているだけですと
本来の姿というものはない
何にもない 本来の自分というものもない
普通私たちはそう言うんですね
今 私はちょっと年取ってるんだからと
これ何かに比べて言うんですね
じゃあ本来の自分がどんな年でどんな
そこは全然ないんです
だからいつでもいるのは自分であって
その今のいる自分は次の瞬間の自分とは違うであると
そういう仏教の真理というのは
かなり修行して 心を開いて成長して
知恵が爆発させちゃって体現しなきゃわかるもんじゃないんです
どうしても感情的に いくら
いくら言ったっても バラの花は綺麗やと
いくら人生は苦しみだと言ったって
やっぱり楽しいやと思っているのは普通の人間の考え方なんです
ですから 我々の普通の状態
修行して悟ってない状態を説明するために
モウハという言葉を使っているんです
そこは全ての隅の元ですと
なぜならば バラの花見たら
あ それは綺麗だと思っちゃったら
それは嘘でしょうに あ
だから持っていかなくちゃいけないと思ったりするでしょう
そこで執着生まれるでしょうに
バラの花見て綺麗と言っても
別に綺麗とかなんとかではなくて
今の瞬間でこのものがここのいろんなものを集めて美しさを演奏し
演じているんだと じゃあバラの花には赤とか黄色いとか色があるでしょ
じゃあ暗い部屋に持っていってください
どんな色ですか？と それ色はないんです
その時は ダークルームですから
この全く暗い この光が当たらない部屋に持っていったら
もう何のこともない 何も色を持たないんです
ですから このバラの花が赤くてすごい綺麗やというのは
ある光の中でそうであって
赤いバラの花を持っていて
真っ赤な光の中で見てください
どんな色をするかというと
全然染まらないんです
じゃあ青い光の中に持っていってください
黒く見えちゃうんですね
綺麗じゃないんです それからみんなこの白い服なんか着てるでしょ
あの あの あの 何て言ったっけ
この池袋とかエチトピアの下からあの三千世界なんかああいうのに行くと
ずっとあの あの 何の光ですか？紫外線？光の蛍光灯いっぱいあるんですね
ですから みんな光り輝いてるんです
着ている服からもうチラチラチラチラと
普通の光の中にいたら
またごく普通の服なんですね
特に白い服を着ていると
その白い部分が全部もう光ってるんですよ
ですから みんな子供たちやら若者やら
そのトンネルの中通る時はものすごい楽しくて
ワイワイして でもその時で誰も欲は作らないんですね
やっぱり私はすごい豪華な服着てるんで
これ光り輝いてるんだとか
私には超能力があるんだとかね
まあこれから開祖宗教でも作る
そんなことは思わないでしょうに
それはこの光の中にいる時だけやと思うと
たまにあれこっち行ったりこっち来たりとかね
子供たちとかね 試したりもするでしょ
だからその場合はいくらか知恵があるんですね
これは一時的であって
この光に当たったら自分の服はあの光を出してるんだと
それは真理の世界 すべてのものがそうであるとなぜ理解しないかと
ですから バラの花は ああ
これは赤くて綺麗やというのは
ある光の中で赤くて綺麗であって
ダークルームの場合は何も色を持ってないし
それは青い色やら他の色の中で黒く見えちゃうし
全然綺麗でも何ともないし
ですから 人間にはそれは理解しないんだから
バラの花は綺麗だと 金というのは大変高価な金属だと
ダイヤなんかはもう石ではなくて大変高価なものだとかね
と思ったりして喧嘩したり
欲を作ったり 執着をしたり
これは私の国だと あれは隣の国だと思ったりして
そこで国同士で戦ったりとか
そういう全ての一切の人間の苦しみ
戦争 戦い 怒り 嫉妬 なんだかんだこの真理
このわずかな真理を知らないんだから生まれるんです
それを知っていると 私の国もないし
他人の国というものもないし
ここに私という人物もいないし
何もないんです 全ては空であること
空っていうのは現象であるっていう意味なの
同じ意味なんですね わかるんですね
ですから このモハだけは問題なんですね
モハさえなければ もう何も問題なし
モハっていうのはそういう風に真理に悟ってない状態ですから
誰にでもあります それあるんだから我々は誤解して
美しいものがあるんだ
美しくないものあるんだとかね
価値のあるものあるんだ
価値のないものあるんだと思ったりして
いろいろ感情して他の罪を犯してしまっちゃう
ですから罪の元 下手な生活するしていることのもと
悪習慣のもとがもう ですから
それだけ理解すれば全部終わりと思いますけどね
もうだけ問題なんです
無常であることさえ理解すれば
もう飛んでいっちゃうんです
全部終わるんですよ 問題は
では 次の言葉いきます
アヒリカ  これからそんなに大胆ではないんです
アヒリカっていうのは
このヒリという言葉があります
ヒリ めっちゃやらいヒリ
ヒリっていうのは恥という意味なんですね
恥 恥ずかしいという で
ア入っちゃったらそれはないんだと
まあカっていうのはそういう状態であるという名詞なんですね
ですから カがあってもいいし
なくてもいいし そのそのそのその経典によって
それなりにいろいろ言葉変化して使ってます
で 意味はすごいわかりやすくて
この悪いことをするには何の恥も感じないとというぐらいの意味なんです
普通だったらこのけしからんなことはできないんですよ
恥ずかしくて 例えばどこへ行っても大声で喋りましょうと
恥ずかしくて喋れないでしょうね
ですから 恥ずかしいんだから
我々は行儀よく振りまうんです
例えば女性の方でも 電車なんかに座っていると
なんか足元がなんか大体まあちょっと冷たくなってくるし
もし足を上に上がってのんびり座りたくなったと
でもやらないでしょ そんなことは
それ恥ずかしいんだから
ですから 足元は冷たく感じたっても
なんとなく気持ちちょっと良くなくたっても
なんのことなく行儀よく座っている
そこで汗が出たりしたら
もう誰でも着ているものを脱いだりしてして
こうこうやってしたり
それは気持ちいいかもしれませんだけど
男はやるかもしれませんだけど
女性はそういうことはしない
なぜかというと やっぱりそんなことはやりません
恥ずかしいんですよ そういう心理で人間にこの恥という気持ちさえあれば
自分を自然にコントロールするんです
ここで言っているのは
それはないと 別に恥ずかしくないよと思っちゃったら大変危ないんです
こちらの用語としてあるのは
あの 無惨 無惨という これはまあこのプライドとか見栄とかそういうとこじゃなくて
大体もう人間に誰もね
まあ余計なことをしてはいけないというふうな
この なんか動物に多分あるような感じがするんですよ
やっぱりこの もう脅す
脅しちゃって 脅されちゃって
怖いことやらないわけではなくて
自分たちがそんなことをやらないというふうな
いろいろとこあるんです
わずかですけど 人間には大体結構あるんです
この恥という気持ちが
生まれた時からもうあるんですね
で それがあるならばいいんだけど
ない場合は悪いことをしてしまっちゃう
恥っていうことがなかったらコントロールしない自分を
3番目アノッタッパ そこでこちらにオッタッパという言葉があります
オッタッパっていうのは怖いということ
で アノッタッパになっちゃったら怖くないと
何に怖いかというと この恐怖感とかそういうものではなくて
悪いことをするのは怖い
[背景音]ですから今この前女性の例出しちゃったんだけど
男性の場合は大体怖いんだから
自分をちゃんと行儀よく振り回ったりするんですね
電車に乗ったって どこに行ったってもいろいろことをやりたいんだけど
やっぱりそんなことやっちゃったらちょっと危ない
これはやばいと どうもやめたりする
ですから 女性も男性もほとんど問題を起こさずに
行儀よくしっかりと生活しているんですね
怖くさえなければ 男性の方は何やるかわからないんです
でもそこはこの例として理解するために言っただけで
それは別に性別あるわけじゃないんです
このザンとキには 無惨無きっていうのは別に性別の問題ではなくて
誰にでもありますし あるならばいいんです
無惨無きあったっちゃったら
それは不善であって で
普通なごくごく普通な心のある状態なんですね
悪いことをするのは怖いっていうのは
まあただ怖い それだけのことで
いわゆる悪いことしちゃったらね
悪い結果出てくるでしょ
それは大体知ってますし
普通の世界では大体男の人々はいろんなことをやりたがってますけど
やらないのは怖いんだからなんです
女性もいろんなことをやりたいんだけど
やらないのは恥ずかしいだからなんです
あまり怖さは女性にはあまり気にあまりないんですね
例えば女性がある男性を見たら気に入ったと
その人知らないと じゃあその人に言って話して
どうですか？結婚でもしようかと
そこまで言わないんですね
もうそんなことは恥ずかしいとか
男の人はある女性のことを気になって気に入ったと行って
もう喋りたいんだけど
もし断られたらどうしようかとかね
あっち行きなさいなんと言われたらやっぱりこれはやばいと
そうすると怖さ感じちゃうんですね
もうちょっとやめようと
そういう風に 大雑把にはそういう機能しているような感じですけど
そこでコントロールされてるんですよ
誰かに神様にコントロールされてるわけではなくて
我々の心にあるこういう状態で
我々は行儀よく生きてるんですね
それはいい方向へ それがちょっとコントロール失っちゃったら
もう危ないんです 女性の恥ずかしさ消えちゃったら
もう世の中にもいない方がいいぐらい
みんな逃げた方がいいんです
同じこと男性の場合も怖いという概念さえ捨てちゃったら
もうそこですごい恐ろしい世界が生まれている
そこでこの善悪の場合も
この無惨無期というのはいつでもセットで一緒に
そこは無惨無期がある場合は確実にやることは悪い
いわゆる自己コントロールを失っちゃう
ですから 無惨無期というのは心理的な用語で言うなれば
これセルフコントロールなんですね
どんな人でもセルフコントロールありますでしょ？自己コントロール
このセルフコントロールの鍵は
仏教で言ってるセルフコントロールの場合はザンとキーなんですけど
セルフコントロールを失っちゃったら無惨無期
無っていうのはないっていうことで
なくなったと それでセルフコントロールなしということ
4番目ウッダッチ ウッジャットはわかりやすく
本当は難しいんです 説明は
全く集中力ない状態だと理解してください
集中力ない状態 混乱状態
焦っている状態 で イリーはわかりやすい
上がっている状態ありますね
何かやるとものすごく上がってしまっちゃうと
あれはもう徹底的にウッダッチな状態なんですね
上がったら何もできないでしょ
そういうのはウッダッチの状態なんですね
混乱状態 集中力ない状態
何かやろうとすると 人の前で
特に人の前で結構上がってしまっちゃうし
自分の発表なんかあるんだけど
自分の番が回ってくるともう上がってしまってます
それは世の中ではよくあることで
いろいろ面接なんかあるでしょ
いろんなところに入りたくて
ああだこうだとか もううちの中ではもうやるぞ
ああだこうだとか いろいろ準備して
まあ言ってます 面接場に行って
自分の名前を呼ばれた瞬間からもう完璧に上がってしまって
もうどうしようもない
それはウッダッチなんです
上がったらしまったら誰もいいことはしないんだからね
例えばもう音楽の世界に入りたくて行ったんだと
歌う人として入りたかったんだと
そうすると歌唱力なければいけません
面接でじゃあこれこれこれ歌ってくださいって言っちゃったら
上がってる人はもう歌うところが全部間違っちゃうでしょうね
それで声は出ないとか
それでもう不合格となってしまっちゃうんですね
だから自分持ってるものが出なくっちゃうんですね
そういうことで 仏教ではそれは不善にカテゴライズしているんです
いわゆる下手でしょ そういう状態
心にあると 前言ったでしょ？クサラはもう上手巧みということだから
だからもうこんなウッダッチが入っちゃったら
もう当たり前にもう下手なんですね
能力は出てこない 失敗する
そこでここもう一つ この仏教的な心理があります
人は悪いことをすると
その瞬間で誰であろうとも混乱状態です
すごく上がっている 落ち着いてはない
集中力はない 自分が何をやっているかと全くわからない
例えばすごく落ち着いて
お医者さんが手術するような感じで人を殺せますか
包丁を持って だから医者も刃物を持って人を切ったりするでしょ
同じことやってますよ
でも何のことなく もうお互いにしゃべりながら
これからこうします これからああします
これからなんとかなんとか動脈を切ります
ここでクリップします
ああします ああだこうだとか言いながら
はい これ取りますとかね
で 終わりました これこれしますとか言って
何のことなく人を体切って中身は取り捨てちゃって
また閉めたり縫ったりして終わったりしますね
その時はちゃんと集中力あるんです
ちゃんと落ち着いているんです
医者でも落ち着きがなくなっちゃったらどうします？自分の命は終わりと
まあそれすごい訓練しているんだから
別に落ち着かなくなるということはないんだけど
だから心配 心配する必要ないんだけど
それでもやっぱりね 精神状態はかなり手術に効きますよ
ですから落ち着きがないと失敗する
上手な人も下手な人になる
ですから ウッダッチが入っちゃったら
やることはすべてアクサラであってクサラではありません
ありません 不善であって善ではありません
仏教で言いたがっているのは
どんな悪い行為であろうとも
それやってる瞬間 その人は混乱状態にいるんだと
上がってるんだと 自分が何やってるかわからない感情というか
もう自害意識もないぐらいな状態で
それに反対に瞬間でも瞑想することはすごい善行だと言ってるんです
なぜならば その瞬間でも落ち着く
瞬間でも自害意識がある
例えば吸います 吐きますという瞬間で
自分が吸ってると吐いてるという
それわずかなことなんですけど
自分の自害意識なんですね
今までなかったんだから
ですから たとえ一回だけでも吸います
吐きますと言っただけでも
かなりの徳を積んでるんです
私から言うとほんのわずかかもしれませんだけど
そんなわずかじゃないんです
すごい徳を積んでるんです
そちらの反対はウッダッチということ
そこで基本的な四つのセット
その四つ揃ったら悪い心
次のセット ローバディッティマーン
ローバディッティマーンという密数
こちらでトンケンマンと書いている密数なんですね
トン むさぼりのトンですね
邪見のケンと高慢のマン
で どんな心 例えば悪い心が生まれる場合は
このモーハの 4つがある
まず確実にあります それにプラスして
もしローバが生まれたら
貪 むさぼりが生まれたら
その心はむさぼりの心という
欲の心で言うんです だから我々にとってはモーハっていうのはさっぱりわかりませんだけど
欲の心ぐらいわかりますね
ですから 心に欲が生まれたら欲の心と言われるし
やっぱりモーハが何か乗ったとなければ欲が生まれません
ローバの説明をまず聞いてください
いつでも欲と欲と欲とかなんとか言うんだけど
なぜ欲欲と言うかわかってないし
欲というのは 人間中心に考えちゃうと人間の認識の問題で
我々は眼耳鼻舌身意という 6つのチャンネルで認識しているんですね
そこまでは今もうわかっていると思います
目耳鼻とか通って物事を知っている
そこで眼耳鼻舌身だけじゃなくて意ありますね
意識というか 心っていうか心で物事を考えるということが認識なんですね
そこで我々には認識チャンネル6つあります
この 6つの認識チャンネルに 6つの情報が触れるんですね
だから我々は一切知っているわけじゃなくて
6つのチャンネルに感知できる情報だけ知っている
目で感知できる情報は色として知っている
何覚？視覚 目で見ることが何覚ですか
視覚が生まれる で 耳に感知できる情報は聴覚として知っている
そこで意で感じるものは
知識から考えてるとか何とかで
心の働きとして知っている
じゃあそういうことは眼耳鼻舌身意に色声香味触法というものは触れるんだとということで
それで触れたものが 触れたものが
逆らわなくていいんじゃないかと
よかったと思う心がローバなんです
で 耳にはもう説明しますけど
耳にいろんな音入る その入る音の流れの中で
あるいろんな音について
我々はこれはいい音 これはいい音
これはいい音と決める
いわゆる心でそれは受け入れる
その受け入れたがる情報について欲が生まれるというんです
それすごい自然的に自動的に現れるものなんですね
で あの ある ある場所でいろんな人が
例えば今このエレベーターのあの音がありますね
あの警告音ってすごい気持ち悪い警告音でしょ？私にとってはね
で そこで誰かが他の人も何か声で綺麗な声で警告音出ると同時に喋っていたんだと
耳がすぐ警告音 あれは嫌ですけど
あの人の声はいいやと
もう決めちゃうんですね
一緒に音が入ったっても
ちゃんと受け入れる音と受け入れたくない音っていうのは区別はそこに現れちゃう
で 私たちは仏教の立場から言いたがっているのは
この世の中で美しい音は存在する
美しい見るものは存在している
美しい味があるとか そんなことじゃなくて
あなたの体にぶつかる情報に対して
あなたはどんな態度をとっているかと
だから ある人がある味に味を受け入れるということは
その人はその味に欲があると
塩味が好き 皆様方はこのイカの塩辛とかね
美味しいと思って食べたりする
塩味はすごく受け入れにくい
私はもう全然食べ物だと思ってないんですね
びっくりするんです 口に入っちゃったら
そうやるとみんななんか変な顔で見るんで
なんだこんなに美味しいものって
だからそこは別に塩辛自体が美味しいか美味しくないかではなくて
ある人がその味を受け入れる認識で
ある人はその人の認識で受け入れたくない
そこで美味しいか美味しくないかっていうのを決めてしまっちゃうんです
だから猫のラブソングは人間は聞きたくないでしょ
鳥のラブソングだったら聞きますけど
でも猫にとってはそれすごい綺麗な音だと思いますよ
人間にとっては あんなのは猫がこう言うね
そういう何時期ですか
そういう交尾なんかやってる時期になっちゃうと
出す音っていうのは聞いたもんじゃないんです
すごいひどい声で 大体みんな追い払っちゃうんですね
あの声で鳴くと 石でも持ってもうあっちへあっちへとかね
それぐらい人間にとっては受け入れたくない気持ち悪い声で
でもあれは猫のラブソングなんですね
そういう動物のラブソング
人間みんな嫌いというとそうじゃなくて
じゃあ鳥なんかはお互いに歌って恋をしていると
みんなそこで聞いてるんですね
ああ 綺麗な声だとかね
だから一般で言えば 生命の互いのラブソングというものが
誰でも聞いて楽しいというならば
それはそういうことじゃなくて
ただ ある音は私たちは受け入れる
ある音は受け入れたくないと
それだけのことです ですから
世の中に音楽なんかは存在しているわけじゃないんです
聞いてる人々 ああ綺麗だと思ってくれれば音楽であって
なんとうるさいと言っちゃったら
それはただのうるさい雑音である
同じ音であろうと じゃあ年
まあ年ぐらい前の時代の人々に
今の現代音楽なんか聞かせちゃえば
ひどい目に遭うだろうと思いますよ
ですから 別に世の中のことは別に
その時その時の人々の受ける感覚の問題ですからね
だから仏教の世界っていうのは
物事にとらわれることなく
あの あの なんてハツの葉っぱの上にある水たまりのように美しすぎるんだと
あのハツの葉っぱの上に水を入れちゃったら
水一滴だけあっちこっちあっち行くと全然塗れないんですね
葉っぱに だからまあ悟った人の心はそういう世の中にいるんだけど
世の中と関係ないんだと
そういうことできるし
そうでない人々は まあまあ
今現代 今のファッションの流行ってるファッションは何ですか？とかね
今どんな色が流行ってるかとかで
それ全部いちいち気にして気にして受け入れて生活しなくちゃいけないし
囚われて囚われて囚われて生活しなくちゃいけないし
ということで 音楽にしたっても
音楽っていうものがあるわけじゃなくて
その聴いてる人々の耳がそれは受け入れるかないかとということで問題で決めると
それで 意の場合は知識の場合も
我々はたまに何か考えると楽しく考えてるんですね
妄想することは好きで妄想している
やむやむを得ないというか
それでもやりたい妄想している場合も
そこで受け入れているので対象が
じゃあそこまで説明は終了して
その対象 眼耳鼻舌身に触れる色声香味触法という対象がいいと決め
受け入れちゃったら その状態が漏というんです
漏っていうね 欲というんですね
だから俗的にあの人欲張りですよとかいう
それとはすごく若い 訳が違う違うんです
厳密に定義があるんです
だから音を聞いて欲が生まれる
ものを見て欲が生まれる
香りを嗅いで欲が生まれる
味を味わって欲が生まれる
体にいろんなものを触れると欲が生まれる
頭で考えると欲が生まれる
欲が生まれるっていうことは
その対象を受け入れる
ですから 人間の中 人間のじゃなくて
生命の場合は一番あるのは欲なんですね
量としては 大体どういうことかというと
誰でも好きなことやってるでしょ
食べるとこは食べたいものを食べてるでしょ
絶対食べたくないって思うものばっかり探して食べてる食べる人はいませんから
今日から音楽を聴きたいんだけど
絶対聴きたくない音楽は何ですかと言って探して聴く人はいませんし
だから普段我々は座りたい時座るし
歩きたい時は歩くし 寝たい時は寝るし
食べたいものは食べるし
喋りたいものは喋ってるし
これ動物も同じなんですよ
ですから 普通の生命の場合は
欲の働きの方が巨大で大きい
一般的に普通 欲はすごく普通です
普通であればあるほど捨てが捨てがたいというか
捨てにくいですね だからこんなみんなこの無責任でいい加減で欲を捨てろとかね
言うんですけどね 今日の本当の状態からはね
そんな無責任でいい加減なこと言えないんですよ
よくこのいろんな説法とかね
いろんなことをすごく
やっぱり欲のない生活はありがたいとね
何してるんですかと聞きたいんだけど
私はやっぱり欲のない生活してるんだとかね
まあまあ 僕はもう頭の中で笑ってるだけで
言えば本当のところから考えちゃうと笑っちゃうだけ
だからみんな一緒で 僕は誰にでもいつでもケチつけてるんではないか
文句言ってるんではないかと思うかもしれません
だけど 本当は実際そうなんですけど
あの立場でなんとかケチつけたくなっちゃうんですよ
なんか偉そうなこと言ってるんだけどっていう感じになっちゃうんですね
本当に欲捨ててるんですかと
だからそんな簡単なものじゃないんです
欲を捨てたそうと思ったっても
ここに食べ物は 4つ並んだところで
あなた 1つ選んで食べなさいと言っちゃったら
その中で一番食べたいものを選ぶでしょうね
何が一番まずいかと この 4つの
はい これに決めます そういう人がいないでしょ
ですから そんなこのもう無責任でいい加減で
まあ欲のない生活 欲を捨てるとかね
まあもうまあ瞑想なんかやってますから
全然欲がないとかね まあそんな甘いものじゃないんです
結構難しいんです 無常というとことん理解してなきゃ
対象についてクールな心が生まれないんです
私の個人的なやり方で言うたら
例えばここで 4つの食べ物があって
じゃあ私には じゃああなたは先に 1つ選んで食べてくださいと
僕はその場合はいろいろ考えちゃうんですね
何人かいるならば その人々の心を読んでみる
この人何が好きかなと
この人何が好きかなと読んで
おそらくこの人はこれ好きだ
この人はこれが好きだ
そうすると残るのはこれ
だからじゃあこれ私は食べようと
で そこは読めない場合は
自分の体で